c'était chaud donc je suis morrison
soirée débat bosse dur et h 30 à la
maison des soirées jeux
j'ai fait de bonnes blagues de bonne
humeur j'oublie quelque chose dans ma
voiture je vais chercher je suis dans ma
voiture côté passager
moins d'une minute et j'entends très
fort bougent pas ils avaient acheté des
aurait aimé je les avais oubliés dans le
loto donc je suis forcée dans l'auto et
pendant que je suis penché en premier
les prendre dans l'auto une voiture de
police arrête à côté de moi et flash et
lumière non moi semita manche encore un
gars qui avait fait deux reprises à son
goût avec moi je comprends pas pourquoi
ça même plus tard il ya quelqu'un qui
avait un gone pointé sur moi là il
commença à être sur la défensive et puis
il commence à enfiler leurs dents puis
je demander quand vous voulez mais
papier mais c'est à la maison je peux
pas vous donner des papiers que j'ai pas
là mon père ni que j'ai pas les audi
commença à mettre la force 3 mètres la
force moyenne
contre le véhicule le bras au cou je
suis même pas conscient que j'ai des
bras comme ça
mais son pagne lui il me dit baisse les
bras pis j'y arrive pas je dis j'arrive
pas une note elle-même nativement femmes
dans l'auto puis
il me laisse pas le temps avec une
amende de plus de 400 $ piège vous par
là je m'en souviens encore ça la raison
pourquoi ils m'ont interpellé à il
disait que aya eby avait beaucoup de
vols de véhicules dans le coin
d historique mais ce précieux des
messages aux trophées meirieu et de
paint the colour your skin fraude aux
élèves m l'épreuve des systèmes et
christine policing et le fath de legault
gavanon 10 2 de glee
si je prends la définition de systémique
de dire un système au québec le système
chez les policiers dans la fonction
publique un système
qu'on lit mineur était visé ben mouche
pas d'accord avec ça
montre aux policiers
sont également qu'il existe des
disparités dans les interpellations
policières causés par des billets 6 tv
de scifo une enseigne majeure
[Applaudissements]
oui de following méduses indiquent les
deux stars bing métro ni faites ni toi
ni
[Musique]
entre
l'analyse de la preuve est extrêmement
importante et ça vaut beaucoup plus dans
la balance que si c'était moi qui disait
que les policiers sont
fernando fin de saint-michel légaux
créés n'est qu'une poignée nineteen
voir quelqu'un mourir sous nos yeux
morales en agonie pendant si longtemps
entouré surtout deux collègues policiers
qui sont là ils étaient quatre donc on a
une personne un agent qui décident
d'agir là et tous les autres en fait qui
se soutiennent entre eux déjà ça nous
fait comprendre que la police sera
jamais la solution profilage racial
parce qu'il ya une fraternité dans la
police qui rend impossible pour un
policier de ce lever de se dire de
briser lui même la chaîne
many things differently cobac bat
fernando 206 hathaway caisse clinique
reçoit sochaux nice
et noir
l'état nous dit oui y'en a des racines
mais des bruits et wax
c'est une façon de dire on a toujours
entendu l'histoire de la bouche des
autres c'est 300 var nous même raconté
notre propre histoire entre nous c'est
pour nous une façon de lens vous pensez
que ça existe pas on va vous donner une
preuve irréfutable que ça existe oui une
vallée de sa main tendue aux socialistes
or is good as tu eu à chaque fois que je
vois un policier tout de suite je
m'attends à ce qu'ils m'arrêtent tout de
suite et je dirais 60% des cas ça ne
loupe pas dès un jeune âge mes parents
me disaient va à l'école apprendre
profession devient quelqu'un de sérieux
et je me rends compte maintenant que
malgré tout c'est vous conseille malgré
le fait que je les ai suivis je me
retrouve quand même dans la mer
ni policier pour une raison que je les
ignore tu te fais arrêter devant chez
vous pour me demande si c'est devant
chez toi je sais pas si ça arrive au
blanc annonce
[Musique]
des histories échos de finding devenait
indépendante state street chaix in
montreal le switch and bicycle et noise
and teaching
parce qu'une interpellation
c'est une prise de renseignements donc l
insu de laquelle n'y a pas de sanction
il n'y a pas de faute reconnue donc la
personne qui sera interpellé les les
relâcher comme interpol et doni
renseignements et ensuite il s'en va le
twin twin fourtine antoine issa dentyne
street check in christ ou andrée d'une
folie tripper certainement trop black
arms and the news people are stop
fortify times of london wasps des
statuts le monde
donc on a essayé de se dire est ce que
ça pourrait s'expliquer par le fait que
certains groupes comme est plus de crème
et donc forcément ils sont plus
interpellés et donc on a analysé ça il
se rend compte que c'est pas le cas
[Musique]
police six twitch examine the vingtaine
de tours matthews de tourisme spurs
créer des profils
ya des gens qui effectivement sont
jeunes sont noires portent un hoodie une
casquette et conduisent une voiture
relativement luxueuse et eux ces combos
le mix qui va donner lieu à un certain
nombre d'interpellations essais et c'est
un problème c'est un vrai problème ces
gens là ils n'ont pas à subir sans cette
époque jamais une mercedes et 300 sauts
je passe de l'autre côté je vois que le
policier il m'a vu il fait le tour
complètement dans les faits un gros your
turn et il vient se coller derrière moi
la première chose qui me demandent ces
seuils ou allez vous comme ça vous êtes
donc bien chic anna aux laïcs je vais je
m'habille comme ça tous les jours puis
il m'a dit ah ouais je croyais que vous
alliez un mariage donc c'est ton
véhicule produit puis là il me dit
comment tu l'as pays c'était une agente
elle est venue à ma fenêtre et m'a
demandé ce que je faisais ce que ce que
je vendais pour avoir une belle voiture
comme ça à l'époque j'avais
une jolie voiture
je m'étais fait plaisir je mettais déjà
fait demander qu'est ce que tu fais dans
la vie pour avoir une belle voiture
comme ça avec qu'est ce que tu avances
j'étais un peu fâché la question puis là
il me dit tu ont permis un permis
étranger
est ce que tu es étudiant j'ai dit oui
je suis étudiant est ce que vous voulez
que je vous montre ma facture des colis
peut-être donc je vous montre la preuve
qu'il ya un revirement qui a été fait
est là il commence à me poser d'autres
questions a-ton paix et fait quoi dans
la vie elle m'a demandé de sortir du
véhicule
là je me rappelle même dit ok ouais là
c'est réel c'est sérieux à la vider mon
sac sur le sur le le capot de la voiture
elle a vu ma carte d'identité qui était
accroché à lens de mon sac est toujours
là et elle s'est rendu compte que
j'étais en fait médecin que je travaille
à l'hôpital
puis et maintenant dumas 4ème à
souhaiter une bonne soirée comme si de
rien n'était c'est en plein milieu de la
rue tous mes effets sont encore au sol
sur la valeur c'est humiliant
plus une expérience unique
il y en a beaucoup comme on a vu lors du
marathon qui le vivent jour après jour
année après année décennie après
décennie des gens qu'ils écoutent j'ai
été interpellés plus que cent fois dans
ma vie
essayez de trouver des personnes
blanches qui sont capables de raconter
ce genre d'expérience à ça existe
presque par la most en que j'ai nostang
jones aline je laime c'est mon véhicule
gp je me levais le matin à 6 heures pour
aller travailler à l'autobus dans le
centre-ville
j'ai gagné mon véhicule j'ai le droit de
le conduire c'est qu'il a des mac 20
pouces que ça soit une banque lui que ça
soigne lemken l'homme noir a le droit de
conduire son véhicule il pas obligé
d'avoir un toyota corolla pour la
première fois une organisation policière
québécoise j'ai encore d une
interpellation une activité réalisé
quotidiennement dans les patriots de new
par le cndd street chaix rights of may
not be and after pré-show profiling pics
de
probation
c'était juste le fait de quelques
individus mal intentionnés bas ce serait
assez facile à régler controller vous
avez qu à les identifier puis à les
mettre dehors il y en aurait plus de
racisme y aurait plus de discrimination
le fait que ce soit aussi durable ou si
un répandue que ce soit aussi
systématiquement retrouver c'est bien la
preuve que le problème c'est pas le
quelques individus mal intentionnés mais
que c'est un racisme qui est systémique
c'est à dire que c'est le système qui
produit en cl c'est la manière d'un
système fonctionne
[Musique]
pas évident de vote de système 9h25
[Applaudissements]
premièrement merci 12 est déplacé
d'environ plein saut d'arrivée qu'on a
ici mais ne sent pas s'étonner qu'une
tribu la première sans
changement la main d'un repas fallu
continuer le combat juste
[Musique]
stéphanie germain est venu generation
chaque tonne de status quo
c'est quelque chose qu'on oublie c'est
que le racisme tue c'est sûr qu'on peut
pas rester indifférent ce parce qu'on a
vécu aussi qu'on le vit au quotidien sur
l'a6 mal
ça fait partie de notre quotidien
juste à cause de la couleur de foot et
puis je trouve une épopée tard alors que
dans le ton les pumas on a tous les
goûts
quoi qu'on pense
à la mort de floride on peut ne pas
penser à fredy villanueva abonnés
jean-pierre un marseillaises françois à
toutes ces personnes qui ont perdu la
vie entre les mains des forces
policières
donc évidemment que ça ramène des
traumas qu'est ce qui a changé
au fond des filets 26 de faillites
du régime il serait actuellement environ
2000 haïtiens à vivre légalement au
québec
l'enquêteur spécial du gouvernement du
québec estime qu'on ne peut humainement
les renvoyer dans leur pays des immigrés
décédés
john sweeney non
ils ont dit aux gens qu'on que la police
allait les matins fort dimanche qui
était le prison de duvalier qui
torturait les gens la police les uns lui
a dit qu il allait lui non c'est à
travers le pont champlain en ligne et
d'ampleur
les quatre accusés ont plaidé non
coupable aujourd'hui en cour municipale
à diverses accusations allant de l'
entrave au travail d'un policier à
l'évasion d'une garde légale
de black comedy et choisissent de police
en précisant
qu'ils font leurs ouvrages points noirs
blageon toutes les couleurs je vois
vraiment pas le choix pour
discrimination au niveau de la police je
vois que ça peut être tendu à l'occasion
puisse est appelée à être toujours tendu
je pense pas que ça vienne casser régler
ça fait partie de nos comportements
nos vins buntin et des saveurs de thé en
chine une crise
que s'est il passé au juste dans le
stationnement du poste de police d'un
quartier de montréal hier matin a priori
les faits sont éloquents un jeune noir
de 19 ans anthony griffin a été tué
d'une balle dans la tête alors que
pourtant ils venaient d'obéir aux
policiers qui lui demandaient de ne plus
bouger si c'est enfin de manoeuvre pour
tenter s'enfuir un policier
a été tué atteignant la victime à la
tête comment un policier peut-il avoir à
ce point la gâchette légère
grinsted ce
procès mes lecteurs de fichiers joints
des demandeurs police et 15 pour les
t2 cruellement
actuellement à la cmm ce sont des
officiers de police qui jugent du bien
fondé des pintes citoyens dans les cas
d'abus de pouvoir ou de brutalité
policière
une pratique qui manquerait de
crédibilité c'est tout le cycle à
l'opinion de tous de tous ceux qui
changent de banque au département de
crédit vide d'un fanzine l'édito de
crèches une veine indépendant de police
est exclue mairie
c'était bon programme c'était utile il
fallait le faire mais ça va changer oui
c'est in sweden de force remains ce tron
winnie officers and funding is filed
under a officieusement à weeds in it
used in chief of giving tout près
il y avait vraiment prise de conscience
qu'on a un problème
alors on va demander pourquoi avec tout
ça est ce qu'on a eu on les prises
toujours avec les mêmes problèmes et je
pense que l'une des raisons c'est que
l'institution la police et la fraternité
des policiers de montréal en sont des
institutions avec beaucoup de pouvoir
qu'ils sont pas transparents qui sont
palpables au citoyen
[Musique]
9 heures
et maintenant
on reproche souvent la police et aux
directions alcool de sous-évaluer la
montée de la violence chez les jeunes et
le phénomène des gags le métro les
autobus nos écoles sont moins sûrs qu'il
ne l'était la violence des jeunes est
plus imprévisible du spontané les
agressions contre les personnes
augmentent et le port du couteau quand
ce n'est pas celui des armes à feu peut
donner lieu à de véritables tragédies
humaines la panique commence à se
répandre dans la population
faced with whitebread public une semaine
pour l'is institute of rust
de
textes
toujours le dépeindre le mariage
généralement blancs ils ont pris un
moment pour dire que les gangs de rue
moi c'est un vrai problème tout le monde
et on va faire toute une histoire pour
lutter conte les jeunes intense entre
racisées
mais non c'est pas possible de personnes
noires aussi
été menées ce contexte de crise mystique
sweeney folio aux marseillaises françois
et yange américaine blake suspecte et
guay de
saint germain des
prés
cette opération a été un échec
elle remet en cause la crédibilité du
service de police dans ses relations
avec les citoyens et citoyennes et
soulève plusieurs questions sur nos
méthodes de travail
j'ai reconnu qu'on a fait une gaffe on a
fait une erreur
il ya une personne personne qui est
décédée
violemment par un coup de feu qui ont
été tirés par la police
[Musique]
members are enough tout de suite
du
tournoi ag les intentions de tentations
pourquoi ces personnes non invitées à
peine on veut agir on veut plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me rappelle du ministre de la
sécurité dans le temps mais schirrhein
qui me sert à rien ça vous coûte cher
votre transfert
d'espèces de résistance de police
dans les années 80 on a commencé à
s'interroger on a dit comment ça se fait
que la police à montréal elle est
masculin blanche 5 pieds 9 puis
française on a fait en sorte de faire
modifier les normes dans bausch alors ça
ça lui a ouvert les portes aux femmes
purgeant des communautés
ethnoculturelles
on a dérangé ont dérangé aussi à
l'intérieur de l'organisation parce
qu'on trouvait que on mettait beaucoup
d'efforts là dedans mais c'est pas
facile de changer des mentalités
[Musique]
michel
stefani cher mais ça peut être difficile
à comprendre pour certaines personnes
pour qui la police représente la
sécurité mais la police ne veut pas dire
sécurité pour tout le monde
pour plusieurs jeunes de montréal nord
la police est pas synonyme de sécurité
montreal world et the blind side
avait pas dans
mon coeur commence à palpiter beckham
police sur la route peu importe l'heure
rien à me
reprocher
j'ai quand même des palpitations fait
que j'imagine que ça voudrait dire que
j'ai peur de la pole est présent mais
quand tu es en panique tu dois appeler
la police moi aujourd'hui à prendre
trois ans est-ce que je vais le faire
[Musique]
l'habitude que j'ai commencé à prendre
c'est de dire tout de suite mon cv aux
policiers monsieur l'agent mon nom c'est
steven charles j'habite à telle adresse
je mets en taule de l'année gk du dhj
s'est entêté l'année voici mon emploi
voici qu'est ce que je fais qui sait
sastre mécanismes de défense que j'ai
appris à faire parce que
l'interpellation pour moi et je sentais
qu'elle pouvait aller dans une direction
[Musique]
e
stéphanie germain grow up and socially
un complexe et demanderait aux nourrices
grandira moyens là ça veut dire aussi
puis je parle pour moi puis parle aussi
pour la part des amis très jeune c'est
d'avoir une relation déjà
étrange avec la police quant au onze ans
tu as raison tu t'assois sur le dossier
du banc que la police t'approches la
géci tu descends pas de là je donnais
ticket puisse continuer affirme attitude
je vais arrêter
quoiqu'il nous dévisagent quoi on sent
qu'on est épié dans notre propre
quartier
[Musique]
swift
données
socio économique oui
l'idée est que tu vises des
environnements des quartiers des
populations où il ya des symptômes de
danger ou de désordre donc des fenêtres
brisées
ok ou des personnes itinérantes et donc
tu vises ces quartiers là
pour agir en prévention de la commune
dont ça veut dire que tu mets plus de
police
[Musique]
pour les erreurs humaines
on était des jeunes en ahl à l'école on
the run a pas décemment payés dans la
criminalité on faisait juste faire des
choses que n'importe quel jeune dans
n'importe quel quartier pouvait faire
c'est-à-dire prennent et dans les rues
j'avais l'impression parfois qu'on
marchait sur des oeufs
tu es survie celui-ci se promène dans un
parc à la police qui rôdent
police de new plan 9 actions focus and
manufacturing
3,6 à
un policier en passant que bon il faut
prévenir la délinquance il faut prévenir
les désordres
il va et plus aptes à arrêter un jeune
noir qui crachent
qu'un blanc qui crachent donc parce
qu'on les autorise à sûr surveiller
certains groupes y vont agir sur ces
incivilités de façon plus intense
[Musique]
soyez des jeunes qui finissent avec avec
un ticket sont pas l'argent pour le pays
se ramasse en cours l'amant faut faire
des travaux communautaires lyon en bus
ils finissent avec un dossier criminel
peuvent pas travailler
on est parti d'un règlement municipal
ont fini avec la vie d'un jeune qui
hypothéquait
by de benq tass de bordeaux le guen
et folie millions $ afin de faire de
l'événement
six mois
l'idée c'était on va vous dire qu'on est
là on va vous montrer qu'on est là on va
vous rappelez vous maintenant vous avez
plus être tranquille parce qu'on va
s'occuper du problème des gangs de rue
et donc on va vous le dire en étant très
présents et en faisant beaucoup
d'interprétations j'étais sorti avec mes
amis et je sors et je décide de les
attendre devant le bar sur seine est
littéralement ils sont sortis avec leurs
fusils fait que j'étais comme encerclé
de trois endroits ils t'ont menotté il
ya plus personne autour de toi mais il
n'écoute pas je me rappelle en ce moment
là j'ai juste répéter encore monstres
une charge suis né en 1923 je réside à
telle ou telle adresse moi je fais juste
leur dire ça pour que en espérant
quelques uns mais coûtent tès puis que
jean ils comprennent que sam aucun
rapport qu'est ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire plus loin
une autre opération coup de poing contre
les gangs de rue à montréal dit cette
arrestation dans l'ouest de l'île il ya
moins d'une semaine la police a arrêté
27 petits caïds à montréal-nord et
rivière des prairies de street games à
200 coureurs participent hip hop ou de
la spvm a produit un document pour les
policiers qui identifiait certains
critères de jeunes supposément
délinquants
dans laquelle il y avait des affaires
trek des clichés ok donc un des quatre
critères étaient bling bling et je n'y
as pas
leurs critères étaient
graffitis un autre critère était
habillement époque qu'est-ce qui est
loch bout d'oreille en or c'est des
criminels non j'ai des dents non c'est
un bijou je l'aimais je me sens bien
avec ça fait pas de moi c'est un
criminel ou vernon
karla homolka veut pas de lock là
the war games continue
[Musique]
about six districts en cela nous avons
été nuls john isner
chaude
[Musique]
pour yaya rien fait d'illégal torcé
paquet en russie
[Musique]
moi ça a été mon premier réflexe est de
dire ben non vous vous trompez c'est
sûrement quelqu'un d'autre ne s'est pas
fait
puis après quand j'ai comme réalisé en
fait que
que c'était vrai il a été vraiment un
gros choc
a été terrible
[Musique]
ils sont pas liés seulement l affaire
villanueva s'est ému que la population
on avait marre se sentait harcelé il y
avait une ras-le-bol dans la population
qui a pu exploser au moment de l'affairé
de moeurs à chaque fois qu'ils aient des
rébellions 1 ap rising rights
c'est à cause de violences policières
toujours toujours toujours on sait tous
vu dans prédit qu'on s'est vus on serait
revenu là dedans parce qu'on se dise on
se dit finalement ça aurait pu arriver à
n'importe qui suite aux émeutes ou ce
qui est arrivé c'est de dire que plus
jamais jamais il ya des jeunes qui va
perdre la vie aux mains des forces
policières
demandent la police
mon nom c'est pierre paraire je suis
franco ontarien et avec des extraits
écrits je travaille à montréal comme
intervenait pour les inclut autochtones
sans abri souvent que la police y
arriver vous vous et moi comme un autre
sans abri bois comme une personne
différente ou moins qu'une personne la
seule peine qui arrive le plus long
mandat c6 c'est d'arrêter ou de donetsk
est ou de quoi que ce soit que tu es
ville offert aux niches c'est comme si
tu nous lis belge comprennent les mots
sortent leur gauche que c'est que tu
fais ici de base
est une
réalité quotidienne
orpheline de sa lignée de singes double
axe indians pipolo more likely to be
startin tchèque l émir de coûts il a 20
ans - mais qui se vouent une haine a
deux matches à jouer comme ça à soi
nous avons maintenant des chiffres nous
avons des chiffres qui nous montrent ce
que les penseurs autochtone et racisées
nous antilles depuis des décennies c'est
à dire que la police mais à celle les
oppriment les criminalisent les traite
comme vision citoyens comme des non
humains
de rhuys in finding soundchecks
smartstream réaction mais fort de ses 10
public safety commission
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
je ne saurais commencer cette maj
soviétique
on nous écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est vraiment
la première fois une politique bien
tadic une interpellation doit être
fondée obligatoirement sur des faits
observables et ça motive ce qu'il n'a
pas moi je me suis posé beaucoup de
questions on essaie de comprendre un
fait si un fait pas observable c'est
quoi le fait que je sois noir c'est un
fait que quelqu'un peut observer donc
c'est un fait est observable mais si les
interpellations n'était pas déjà fait
sur des faits observables sur quoi
exactement si à montréal que nous
instaurons cette nouvelle façon de faire
je pense que c'était un beau coup
marketing
la politique change absolument rien va
changer rien changé
des fans tchèques
protection
faut pas oublier qu'on écrit cette
politique ne s'est pas produit juriste
spa pour les citoyens mais c'est bien
pour les policiers pour encadrer la
pratique d'une interpellation le fait
que c'est clair pour le possessif on
donne un cadre dans lequel on veut
qu'ils évoluent ou qui fonctionne en cas
d'interpellation mais c'est un aspect
important pour son changement culturel
[Musique]
elsewhere in canada
il est gros
ennahda police mais pour des
[Musique]
réductions ou est ce qu'il n'ya pas
justement une interpellation de routine
mais il ya des enquêtes policières qui
se fond on devient plus intelligent dans
la façon justement dominé nos enquêtes
on ouvre nos horizons et puis souvent
qu'est ce qu'on en fait faire avec les
opérations de routine c'est une partie
de pêche on sait jamais ce qu'on va
pouvoir avoir mais on tombe sur des gens
que nous on voulait intercepté nous on
veut pas aller dans cette avenue l'on
veut que nos policiers faisaient face
interne relation de la bonne façon basé
sur des faits observables puis que ça
sans lien avec notre mission policière
parce qu'on croit foncière mc saïda les
autres des crimes des crimes viennent de
whistler
canada ce geste d'après toi
ce serait utile d'avoir des caméras
donnent tous nos appartements d'avoir le
droit la police d'entrer à n'importe
quel moment c'est toujours bon d'avoir
plus d'informations mais de questions ce
que est ce que c'est juste et avec les
impréparations on voit que non
or pour les dates cause de ce crime et
nation including street chaix should be
bad according to
que ça soit la lutte aux gangs de rue
que ce soit les incivilités que ça soit
les contrôles d'identité
que ça soit l'investissement
disproportionné de ressources dans les
quartiers à racisées à montréal donc
finir avec toutes ces
politiques qui vise de façon plus
intensive ces populations là
je fais de défendre de police comme
nation et non asking damuseau
tout cas des services it started to one
et clichy
il ya encore la violence est encore la
pénalité dans nos communautés ça ça veut
dire que la police s'est peut-être pas
la solution mais nous ce qu'on dit que
moi ce que je dit personnellement c'est
réinvestissant dans nos communautés ça
que je parle des changements de
paradigme ces changements de vision il
faut réussir à transformer
fondamentalement
la mission policière on alice la manière
suivante c'est que
plutôt que de se dire la chose la plus
importante de la police est forcément
juste de lutter contre le crime je pense
qu'on peut dire la chose la plus
importante que de faire la police c'est
de contribuer la sécurité des citoyens
et si vous interpellez de manière
disproportionnée
ils vont forcément injuste une partie de
la population
produisez de l'insécurité
de vous faites exactement le contraire
de l'essence même de votre mission the
government in fine frenzy d'action 65
millions de dollars qui seront investis
en
[Musique]
2009 quand ils m'arrêtent moi je suis en
présence de deux personnes armées qui je
sais depuis cinq minutes cherche une
raison pour être dans mon intimité à
partir du moment où il me parle je n'ai
plus de droit je n'aime pas de bénéfice
du doute
s'ils me tire dessus il aura une
histoire à raconter pour certaines c'est
de ma faute je rêve au jour les morts le
droit d'être ordinaire
j'ai envie de te dire que je rêve de ce
jour aussi
où on n'a pas besoin de faire plus pour
exister et où notre juste le simple fait
d'être noir n'est pas un fardeau de ces
chenilles noir je suis humain tout
simplement puis la même chose que vous
[Musique]